There is now an extensive series of disgusting
but not altogether surprising allegations
that Donald Trump is essentially laundering
money through his campaign and then making
potentially illegal secret payments, including
to his own family with that campaign cash,
hiding the recipients through organizations
LLC as businesses and agencies.
And it turns out that hundreds of millions
of dollars in spending by Trump's campaign
is flowing through to companies with no disclosure
of how the money has been spent.
The nonpartisan Campaign Legal Center is now
accusing the campaign of violating federal
election transparency rules by shielding the
real source of campaign expenditures and the
recipients.
Now, remember that.
I mean, what does it matter?
He lies all the time.
But when he was running for president, Donald
Trump claimed that his administration would
be the most transparent in history as president.
Donald Trump has claimed his administration
is the most transparent in history.
And obviously that is not the case.
The complaint is extremely detailed.
It says payments have been masked but made
to a bunch of Trump's family members, including
people like Eric Trump's wife, Laura Trump,
who doubles as campaign staff.
Conveniently, Don Junior's girlfriend, Kimberly
Guilfoyle on the mend from coronavirus.
I think also doubling as campaigns.
It's not just Don's girlfriend.
It's also a campaign adviser.
They also do a lot of their ad buys through
a company called American Made Media Consultants
and through a private company owned by none
other than Donald Trump's former campaign
manager, Brad Parr.
Scale understand like the incestuous nature
of this until he got demoted.
Brad Parr scale was running Trump's campaign
and directing ad spending for Trump's campaign.
And a lot of the spending was brokered and
filtered through the company that Brad Parr
scale owns.
It's genius, right?
I mean, a great way to line your own pockets.
American made Media Consultants is a company
that the Trump campaign itself controls, meaning
once the payments go from the Trump campaign
to American made media consultants, they go
to whoever Trump wants.
With no transparency, tens of millions of
dollars, by the way, have been run through
Brad Parr Scales Company, and Don Junior's
girlfriend is getting paid 15000 a month,
180 grand a year for working on the Trump
campaign.
Same thing with Larra Trump.
Eric Trump's girlfriend, Brad Parr scale has
acknowledged that he's paying them, saying,
quote, I can pay them, however I want to pay
them.
Now, you probably can understand the way in
which this is a useful method for funneling
money to your friends and family and, of course,
the legal case before the FEC.
It's going to be litigated for a long time.
We likely won't know the outcome until after
the November election.
Certainly I would.
I would bet.
But there should be no surprise whatsoever
that they are doing this because this is how
they operate.
Donald Trump has been doing this his entire
presidency.
Trump Trump has been funneling money through
his golf clubs back into his family's pockets.
Understand that Trump at last count had golf
282 days so far this presidency when he overwhelmingly
that says at his own golf clubs, when he goes
to his own golf clubs, particularly when he
spends the night Secret Service and White
House staff, all rent rooms at his golf club,
Secret Service rents, you know, at dozens
of golf carts, and they pay Trump's clubs
for that.
That money, of course, goes right back to
Trump and to his family.
This is Trump's entire life.
This is how Trump has done business in real
estate in New York City and around the world
forever.
And, you know, there was actually a time where
there would be court consequences for this
type of thing in the United States.
Remember former President Jimmy Carter, Jimmy
Carter's family had a peanut farm in Georgia
and Jimmy Carter separated himself from the
peanut farm so that he couldn't conceivably
be seen as acting in a way that was favorable
to his family's business.
Like imagine that he were to push for certain
laws related to farming that could be seen
as favoritism to his own family's business.
It almost seems quaint and provincial that
that's what he did.
Given what Donald Trump is doing now with
absolutely no rieper.
Cautions whatsoever, this is the type of thing
Donald Trump did his entire life, and it should
come as no surprise whatsoever that he's continuing
to do it.
The only question is, is he going to get another
four years to do it for your weight?
You know, as I've said before, if you're waiting
for Trump to end up in prison, it's not going
to happen if you're waiting for Trump to be
carried out.
You know, let out in hand.
It's not going to happen.
The opportunity is we stop this and he only
gets four years.
He could get another four years to do this
stuff.
And by the way, do his donors care?
Like, if you're a donor and you donated 100
bucks to Trump and you find out 90 of it went
to Brad Parr Scales Company and PA Scale kept
20, and then he gave 20 to Don Junior's girlfriend
and he gave twenty to Eric Trump's wife, Laura.
Trump like if you donated one hundred bucks
and only ten is actually used for an ad buy.
Are you okay with that?
Are you furious?
Or if you're presented with this, do you just
deny the reality and say it's fake news, like,
please, if you're at Trump's than my audience
and I know I have some.
Doesn't this bother you?
Doesn't this just lining everybody's pockets
bother you or do you just not believe that
this is going on?
I want to hear from you and we'll continue
covering this on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page at The David Pakman Show.
We will take a quick break and be back after
this.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.